director of the MIT Communications forum
and a professor of literature at MIT I'm
delighted to welcome you all to today's
Forum let me Begin by announcing very
briefly two of our two final events for
this spring term we've set I think a
very high standard this term and I'm
very proud of the forums we've managed
to put together on Thursday March 21st
our Forum will focus on massive online
courses and their implications one of
our speakers is anant Agarwal who's the
president of the edx program centered at
mict in Harvard a second speaker is the
co-founder of Coursera Professor Daphne
Kohler of Stanford and um
she'll be those those two uh panelists
will be joined by a professor of English
who who has recently been appointed the
president of Lafayette College and she
has a peculiarly humanistic view even a
skeptical view of the power of these
massive online courses what I'm
expecting is a wonderfully rigorous
discussion of a central educational
question and then on Thursday April 11th
we will have a I I hope a very powerful
and interesting debate about the moral
quality of of our press campaigns and
our title is something like news or
entertainment the press in modern
political campaigns and one of our
speakers is our MIT colleague tanahisi
Coates who writes for the Atlantic and
I'm looking forward to that event as
well
now it remains for me now as briefly as
I can to introduce our event for tonight
but let me Begin by saying that Nate
Silver's appearance in this conversation
uh has him join what I think of as an
especially distinguished subset of
visitors to the MIT communication forum
and they include such figures as Stephen
Greenblatt of Harvard and his Harvard
colleague Stephen Pinker the poet
laureate Robert Pinsky so Nate is in
very distinguished company although he
knows a lot more about a good many
things that many of us are interested in
than any of those three speakers uh but
I'm I'm very happy to uh call attention
to that subset of forum activities
because we're particularly proud of them
and I want to also add that tonight's
moderator
um uh uh
has has also also joins uh a
distinguished group of moderators who
include among others my wonderful past
colleague Henry Jenkins uh and the
legendary MIT linguist and uh uh on
Presario
S.J Kaiser J Kaiser so so I'm very happy
that Seth is joining this distinguished
group and my hope is that Seth will
continue to play a significant role in
future forums but our featured speaker
tonight Nate silver surely because of
the size of our audience doesn't really
need an introduction it occurred to me
as I was thinking about his career that
it's an interesting cautionary tale for
MIT students there's something
profoundly entrepreneurial and deeply
intelligent about the way uh Nate silver
has made his career and I'm sure many of
you know about his progress from uh a
batch from moving from a bachelor's
degree in economics from the University
of Chicago
to working as a blogger and a and a
pollster to creating his own blog the
538 Blog then to have been in a sense
hired by the New York Times to become
the uh to so which have proprietary
control of that remarkable blog that had
such a powerful influence on our
response on on the on the recent
election and and predicted it so
accurately well that remarkable career
for is is a kind of model in a way that
I know that many MIT students think
about uh a young person who uses the
qualities and and skills that he learns
in University to sort of be a kind of
entrepreneur and I think uh one of the
things that occurred to me is that many
MIT students might consider given the
nature of uh Nate's career uh to have
taken their statistics courses and their
economics courses and then to have spent
the rest of their time at Fenway Park
but but that may not be the approach the
most appropriate lesson to have to have
learned in any case we're very happy to
have uh Nate silver with us and I uh
turned the podium over over to our two
speakers
um first thank you all uh for coming and
I hope we will keep it Lively enough so
that the folks standing on either side
don't get too frustrated
um the uh hashtag for the event is MIT
Nate silver I'll be monitoring uh that
and we might get some questions
um from the twitterverse as we go on uh
some comments so far are nerds nerding
out standing room only
um
so uh
um but I think the format is going to be
Nate and I are going to talk for about
45 minutes to an hour and then we'll
open it up for questions his new book is
on sale outside uh which means that the
people who are in the Overflow will get
first dibs at buying that and he'll
stick around for a little while
afterwards to um to sign books so
um I wanted to start just going back to
the beginning of your career after you
graduated from school you're obviously
best known for your political work and
your baseball work that isn't what you
started out doing no I and I should say
it's a real honor to be here we are kind
of at Ground Zero for for nerds I think
here in Cambridge but it's a real
pleasure to be here
um but no I started out in uh in 2000
and and the economy was good
back then kind of last year the economy
was good for for a while and I took a
consulting job at KPMG where uh it was
billed as something where I do some uh
some public sector Consulting and some
private sector stuff but I wound up
spending most of my time doing something
called transfer pricing consulting which
uh which concerns tax regulations that
govern how much income a multinational
company can get out of its subsidiaries
you're like well is Singapore is
Motorola's Factory in Singapore this is
it's really boring right so it's
supposed to sound boring uh are they
paying enough the US government for the
cell phone parts that are made in
Singapore etc etc
um and so that was um that was pretty
Dreadful uh I think too many kids
probably do take a job as a as a
consultant but I haven't really thought
very much about about what I wanted to
do despite going to uoc the place where
fun goes to die I tried to have
tried to have fun in college and uh and
my degree was not MIT apparently not MIT
yeah I took a year in in London so I
don't know it's I think it's tough for
uh for someone who's who's 21 or 22 to
necessarily know exactly what course
they want to take in life and I'm
suspicious by the way if there are 21
year olds you know exactly what they're
going to do so it took me a few years to
to realize that um that I was been made
pretty miserable by a job that wasn't
very very challenging and started kind
of rebelling against it in in different
ways some which meant having more fun
with my friends in Chicago but also and
I started to play Pokemon and uh and
develop this forecasting system which
eventually became pakota for baseball
players which I sold to baseball
perspectives and so you well first uh
why don't you just briefly explain what
Pagoda is and why it was seen as so
revolutionary at the time so the the
notion behind well there were a couple
of things that made pakota different one
of which is that when you had seen
projections for baseball players would
say well Dustin Pedroia is going to hit
303 next year with nine home runs and 42
doubles only nine yeah well I don't know
right but some exact some exact sequence
of numbers and it felt to me like what
you should really have is a is a range
of outcomes um or anyone his watch
baseball knows that yeah it's
predictable to a certain degree but
especially for for a younger player you
could have a guy who goes on to be the
next youngster basically the next Mike
Schmidt or the next Kevin award he kind
of cubs disaster basically
um even though they have the same
profile the same statistics up to a
certain age so to capture the range of
forecast is one of the Innovations the
other one was to do it all by means of
of comparable players so in baseball you
have it's the world's best data set
basically you have a very very rich
database for every player you can find
dozens of players in the past who were
similar to Hammond so that's the way we
mapped out different possibilities for
for his career trajectory and so it was
kind of you know it also made it more
more fun and more tangible kind of shows
you the work a little bit more and
that's one thing I try and do in in uh
in the forecasting products I put out
those things have remained true where
number one things are are framed in
terms of probabilities and not
certainties number two is you do show
some of the intermediate steps and we do
get criticism we're definitely not 538
it's not at an academic level of of
disclosure uh but it does show people
the work a little bit as far as how do
you get there and I think that has more
value than uh than uh than a kind of
Black Box approach the journey is often
more interesting than uh than the result
I think and so you developed pakota you
sold it
um to baseball prospectus which is uh
probably the premier sabermetric site
um online saber metrics for people who
aren't familiar with the term uh just
really refers to using statistics in a
fairly sophisticated way to analyze
baseball
um uh and then you move to over to
baseball perspectives yourself so did
your parents or your friends or anyone
think that you were insane for leaving
what I assume was a good paying
consulting job well see most of my
income came from from playing poker at
that time
so there was in 2003 a guy named uh
Chris Moneymaker won the World Series of
Poker and he actually was a an
accountant
um with a job not totally unlike the one
I had right um but he basically is a is
an okay poker player who got who got
really lucky right of course when you
have this turned into a television
broadcast and every decision he's making
is made to look as though it's genius
and perceptive and um and the bad calls
he makes you know are shown whereas uh
excuse me the ones that turned out to be
right right we make a decision that well
you're wrong but if you mean the right
decision to be shown on TV we get edited
out if he made a dub Choice instead
anything about poker run on TV is you
you actually see because of the whole
cam what cards someone has and so uh so
you know poker is really easy to play if
you know what Hanley the person has
right
so people watch us on ESPN and get the
sense like oh I can tell that guy is
bluffing well yes because you know he
has seven news off suit because you know
it's showing them right
so a lot of people they were they were
better at poker than they were and so
particularly online it was possible to
make uh make pretty good money uh
playing poker for for a couple of years
and so uh so that enabled me to uh to
leave my job it was like I would stay up
all night and uh you know make 500 bucks
or something playing online poker to
seven in the morning and catch a cab to
work and kind of sleep in at my desk
right and it's like I don't care anymore
right you kind of work packing the
system a little bit I wish I'd play more
poker actually because now the games
have gotten very tough and you can't
really play online but those things went
together where um it was uh less of a
financial leap than it might seem
because I had two different ways to to
make income and and so you can't play
poker online anymore now because
um the sort of naive players who were
over assuming their skills have been
weeded out well there are two things
number one is the U.S government passed
a law in two thousand and uh and six I
think it was
um that um whether it technically banned
online poker or not is debatable but it
made it very hard to get money into the
sites and so what happened is that once
you had the bad players the fish we call
them bust out there was no more ready
supply of them so you kind of had the
whole ecology the whole kind of
ecosystem collapsed basically where the
Predators became
species yeah yeah yeah yeah
um although now I should say uh you know
Nevada and Ninja Jersey this law did
permit seats and as well as subsequent
interpretation by Department of Justice
to do permit states to run their own
online gambling sites so online poker in
Nevada and New Jersey is going up later
this year other states I'm sure will
follow I'm not opposed to uh to gambling
what you have seen in general context
where gambling is legal and one
jurisdiction then it becomes legal and
neighboring jurisdictions because you
know you're otherwise just giving up
money basically right so so you probably
will see
um a Revival of online Pokemon that
plays become a lot more sophisticated
but if you have a lot of new and naive
players then um you know hey look if
you're if you're here at MIT you
probably have a lot of good gainful ways
to make uh to you know to employ
yourself but but do watch another right
if there is another poker boom in in
2014 or 2015 then it might not be a bad
hobby on the side right
um uh so you brought pakota at a
baseball prospectus and then actually
went and joined the site and were there
from when to win roughly so from roughly
2000 into 2003 to 2008 or so
um and you were when you were at
baseball perspectives were you primarily
writing or doing developing more
analyticals it was a combination so
um so I was also helping to to manage
the business and so I was doing like
like three or four things at once which
is I guess something that uh that I've
gotten used to doing
um but it is tricky it was a small
business and in some ways it was ahead
of the curve as we had we had a paywall
very early on and and was basically
successful where it was self-sustaining
and you allowed
um you know a half dozen people to have
an income from it um but also I mean the
competition got a lot better I think in
in a hurry in baseball the competition
in analyzing baseball or or the
um uh the competition from the sense of
the people who are putting teams
together the
had is that it became it wound up being
a a kind of feeder system for for for
Major League teams where I think it must
have had uh a dozen people graduate uh
to go work for for front offices
somewhere
um and uh and that became a real a real
problem
um and you see that now where uh you
know John Hollinger who was ESPN's kind
of the guru of basketball stats and
ESPN's
um you know best kind of basketball
writer got hired by the Memphis
Grizzlies I think it was uh not long ago
so so that kind of it's uh becomes
surprising now where now you can kind of
Make a Better Living I guess on the
inside and the outside whereas super
metrics always began as kind of an
outside agitation against like all these
stupid decisions supposedly that teams
were making and now you see um it's been
co-opted well and and and Bill James is
working for the rest and Bill James
working for is working for the Red Sox
although seemingly from the last couple
of years might not have that much
influence at the moment uh well I you
know I do think it's uh so I guess I'm
one of those rare people where I don't
find uh
you know I wouldn't say never but I
wouldn't find it all that attractive
necessarily to work for a team in part
because I like to be able to um to
analyze data where where your only
incentive is you're kind of your own
boss right and you're able to share your
conclusions with with the broader public
I think that's more um that's more
interesting than taking a conclusion
whereas the same thing I've done
Consulting projects from time to time
right where you find some really
interesting data and you share it with a
room full of of 12 people or something
right it's much less satisfying uh
psychologically than kind of being able
to disclose it to the general to the
general public right
right so
um as you were working at baseball
perspectives and as you were doing all
of this uh you developed what turned
into 538 at the same time right so how
did that start
um so it began I mean you know I think
in a lot of things in life there are
always a few threads that kind of
pulling together in different ways so um
in part because of this law that
Congress had passed in uh in 2006 to ban
online poker I'd follow the ins and outs
of that a lot and then what happened to
um
excuse me to the representatives and
Senators who took the lead in passing
the bill unfortunately a lot of them a
lot of them lost or retired but so that
got me more engaged in politics and then
I was living in in Chicago at the time I
had gone to University of Chicago and so
um so Barack Obama was a name that
um that always like the campus
progresses were always like oh Barack
Obama he'll be president someday right
like give me a break who cares but it
was a name it wasn't him that was
familiar to me so it was kind of
exciting uh to have a candidate who uh
who I you know I felt like was in the
same Circle at UFC was running for
president Lynch that campaign was so
darn interesting between between Hillary
um and Barack and and you know Sarah
Palin and everyone else it was uh it was
a great news story but also I found that
having seen um you know by that point I
think in 2007 and 2008 you had seen a
lot of the Money Ball Clash kind of play
out in favor of of this kind of emerging
consensus where you can use both types
of information you're you have the same
goals ultimately especially with regard
to both types of information meaning
um
this you know and this gets complicated
where I you know I get finicky in my
book about how to use the term
subjective and objective especially
stats versus kind of subjective scouting
views of players and we can break that
distinction down more later on it is a
bit problematic but basically the the
the stack Geeks and the stats versus
makeup yeah we're getting along better
and better
um but it seemed like like politics
coverage was still very stuck in in the
Stone Age is by um by comparison um and
not very data driven at all and so um
and so having seen this development in
baseball it seemed like it was kind of
overdue for for some of the same
approach so it's interesting because in
baseball it seems like one of the things
that that dried or that was the fact
that the people who were actually
putting together the teams were not
using this analysis and that created an
opportunity yeah and in politics six
um if I if I heard you right it wasn't
that the campaigns were not doing this
but specifically that the Press Corps
was yeah so it really was more um so the
the revolution uh so to speak in
baseball happened from uh very much from
the outside in where you know Bill James
was doing this stuff uh uh 20 or 30
years ago
um but you always have had campaigns
that were reasonably sophisticated about
this stuff including
um the the bush row of campaigns in 2000
and 2004 for some reason
um in 2008 and 2012 both John McCain and
Mitt Romney did not seem to learn that
lesson that you want to invest in your
voting targeting efforts but but Obama
did and kind of inherited that mantle in
in 2008 and 2012. um you also had things
like the Howard Dean campaign in 2004
that were that were a part of the story
um and when you say this okay we're
sophisticated about this stuff you you
do you mean
um using whatever data points are
available to craft a a path forward well
particularly the uh you know like I
think it's always dangerous when uh when
campaigns are are too worried about
um here's what the polls I think there's
not often a lot of context about why
people believe what they do so I'm not
one who says that oh campaign should be
dictated by by what the pollster tells
you but this particular activity of of
micro targeting
um where you can say here so the way the
Obama campaign does it simplify slightly
is you have every voter in the country
supposedly is measured by two scores one
of which measures on a scale of zero to
100 where zero means you're a Shore
Romney voter 100 means you're sure Obama
voter and then the other dimension is
How likely you are to vote period
um so you might have someone who who if
they're going to vote they're almost for
sure going to vote for Obama but they
might not vote and they're going to get
a different type of of literature than
someone who um who is definitely going
to vote but they're a swing voter
they're someone who may not be able to
peel off from the Romney campaign so
coming to those profiles based on
collecting all types of information
about someone's name by the way and you
can tell an awful lot about someone just
based on on their name and and where
they live right if you have a name and
address then you know an awful lot about
what their income is their ethnicity
their age actually because different
first names go into style at different
periods of time so just making those
inferences alone you can do reasonably
good voter targeting of course there are
problems like for example I had a friend
who was from from the Philippines
because last name was Rodriguez and so
you have a lot of Heroes get like uh you
know literature targeted toward Mexican
Americans there because a lot of a lot
of Hispanic surnames in in the
Philippines but still you can get you
can get pretty far with that
um and that helped I think both those
campaigns a lot it might not be a
coincidence that um that in 2000 the
team with a better voter targeting which
was Bush and Rove uh won the Electoral
College despite was in the popular vote
whereas uh whereas in 2008 2012 of
course Obama won both but um but if you
break things down then Obama did a
little bit better in electoral college
and The Swinging States and you expect
based on the popular vote nationally
alone so it seems to be worth an extra
couple of points and the Obama campaign
um in in this last election actually
went drilled down to the extent that
they were doing studies as to what email
subject lines were most likely to get
people to open the emails yeah I believe
and I get every kind of spam from every
campaign ever right so it's like hey
Nate about that lunch date yesterday
it's like oh did I you know Miss an
appointment yesterday or something and
uh but you click on that email and after
a while you get you get annoyed by it
and that literally is what the Obama
campaign was doing they found it very
informal like hey look at this it was
much more effective than the future is
at stake or something like that see what
happens if there's some National
Security emergency and like Obama
actually has to get in touch with
someone by email right it would be
really paid
um uh so
um uh so so you you got interested in
politics or you got interested in
working more in politics and then how
did 538 actually come about
um so I started writing it uh at Daily
Coast
um in part because it I know under your
name under anonymously under the
pseudonym poblano which I don't I always
like Mexican food and
um
so it's kind of anonymous and part of it
was uh part of it was I thought well
here I'm known for uh for running about
baseball and you know baseball and
politics don't always intersect that
well um but partly in what way don't
always well I think uh
you know people have strong political
views and I think sometimes you don't
want to think oh that you know that
columnist is an because he's a
Republican or something or a Democrat
um instead of just writing about
baseball first so you'd want people to
to reflect on baseball perspectives
around the work you were doing that was
part of it right apartment it was uh you
know I was kind of playing hooky for my
job against my perspectives to do this
stuff and uh it seems like you have a
history of that I know well every
every I know every future years beware I
don't I hope no one tweets that but yeah
but you know I look I do think it's too
late
I do think in the long run that you're
so much more productive doing something
which uh which captures your attention
right that um you really should do that
90 of the time and yeah they're always
bad days where although I somehow avoid
writing about the sequester I mean
they're they're very slow periods in the
political campaign and there's still
periods and um in the Baseball calendar
and so you know you can't always just
say oh I'm gonna totally not write not
do my job at all
um but in general having a wider range
of topics you can focus on I think is is
something that kind of your career I
think embodies as well but that's super
super duper helpful um you know one
problem that uh a lot of political
journalists have is that look you have
the same amount of column space and a
print paper every day more or less
um but the news doesn't flow that way at
all whereas these peaks of of coverage
where very important things are
happening then you have months and
months where nothing important happens
at all and so some days it should be
like you're just gonna leave this page
blank right no nothing important
happened in Washington day go see a
movie right
but you can't it's not the convention of
political journalism I think that's what
Newsweek decided actually yeah right
um uh so then if you were worried about
alienating your audience what made you
decide to go public I think part of it
is uh is you had people like from from
Newsweek for example the new Republic
would want to to talk to me and it felt
silly to say you know poblano a
synonymous blogger with Daily Coast
right um so at some point it became like
if I wanted to um to to capitalize on
this in any way and being let it grow
grow grow bigger and potentially shift
careers and I had to kind of um had to
kind of out myself I guess uh
and so by the time that you did that you
had some experience with coming into a
field that was fairly set in its ways
and
um certainly uh Sports journalists are
not the most Forward Thinking group of
people in the country
um what was the reaction among political
journalists to your arrival on the scene
in 2008. I think at first it was a
it was actually friendlier at first then
it became later on when you were a sort
of cute little diverse yeah yeah right
someone who was threatening their jobs
yeah before you become someone who
becomes threatening right where um so
you know it did get a lot of attention
in um in the kind of mainstream press
and that helped quite a bit I mean part
of that is you know I the flip side of
having uh cases where there's no news
but you have to have a new story is
cases where there's so much demand for
for coverage and 2008 was uh one of
these historical Years you'll maybe have
you know one of the five Great elections
of the century so you might have one
fascinating election every 20 years or
so and so that's a huge story about the
biggest possible uh political story
except maybe president getting impeached
or something right
um and so you didn't have enough enough
coverage relative to the demand for it
and so um so different ways to look at
it where it was a good time uh to be in
that space and and so uh if I'm hearing
you're right so political journalists
weren't threatened in the same way one
of the reasons was because there was no
fear of someone and reading nade silver
and not reading something else because
people were yeah
um their appetites were endless at that
point that's right and you know I think
partly I you know um
I mean I don't know I was gonna say the
tone of the blog wasn't as combative but
it's probably not true it's actually
probably more more combative it was more
kind of bloggy and and stuff uh but for
some reason so once you start writing
for for the New York Times become more
of a more of a Target definitely
um but also yeah once you once you
realize like you know uh we do actually
have a different model I guess I'd say
so maybe the tone of the blog was
actually more cheeky and more
confrontational and less mature I guess
I'd say back in in 2008
um but I did realize I went along that
philosophy actually have have opposition
to the way that campaigns are covered by
by much of the mainstream press so it's
not just oh here's a different way I
think uh it's like actually
um you guys are doing it doing it wrong
and this blog contains a strong implicit
element of of and sometimes explicit
element of media criticism for lack of a
better term so I I want to come come
back to that but um so in 2008 you you
famously we got 49 out of the 50 states
right was it Indiana yeah yeah you
missed yeah
um and all 35 Senate races right
um and so after that was it clear to you
that this was something that was going
to be more than an election year sort of
sideline and I think so yeah at some
point I mean already by late in the 2008
campaign had become my it become my
full-time job and I'd stopped writing
about baseball I'd stop playing poker a
couple years earlier so so that'll
become fairly clear although if uh if
McCain had had won we had him as a with
a two percent chance to do so then it
would not be a very good career choice I
don't think any longer but um
uh well and that's something I I also
want to come back to but
um uh so two years later in 2010
um you moved over to the New York Times
how did that conversation begin
um so actually uh there's a little bit
of a Boston connection but I went to uh
I went to the MIT uh Sports business
conference in 2010 I guess it was
um and ran into one of the New York
Times editors on the train platform
coming back to New York who was that it
was uh it was uh Gerald marzotti who
runs the who uh ran the magazine right
at that time and is that I think just
yesterday was possibly put in charge of
their digital strategic planning yeah um
and look I think a lot of really great
people at the times and so but when I
ran into him I had also been talking to
other uh other news organizations about
um about bringing 538 on board and I
really did find that um so you know if
you take the times operation as a
digital operation I think it's the best
digital journalism operation in the
world for some reason because it also
has this this print operation which you
can talk about separately it's not in a
pejorative way right but people forget
that this is a really successful
experiment in uh in how to get people to
read feed content online for how content
looks online you know new yorktimes.com
is an amazing this amazing website and I
found the people I talked to there were
were quite Progressive about
um not their politics per se but in
terms of what they thought about where
journalism was headed and so um so they
compared very well I took a long time
several months to make that decision
comparing very well against some other
news organizations that that were
thought of as being more more modern and
digitally focused and so it wasn't an
Easy Choice by any means you hadn't I
mean there was some other very
attractive offers like from what other
news organizations I can't yeah that I
have to be a little bit careful
but different you know different parts
of uh you know yeah I can't say too much
that's fine
um uh but was so at that point had you
pretty much made the decision that you
were going to join some media
organization and not exist on your own
I I think so I think I kind of come to
that
um decision I think part of it is that
uh it's hard to have time to um to both
uh be a Content producer
um and kind of be a a business person
who's managing the brand right Sid is
that um if you if you um lunch time with
someone else then then you have fewer
business decisions to make once you make
that decision I should say you could
maybe have done both but it's also
running a book at that time and just so
it was a way to say look first of all
New York Times is a great way to
distribute your your uh your product but
I think I felt like
um yeah in theory there could have been
a lot of upside to um to building the
business out myself but um but you know
look I think a lot of mistakes are a
mistakes that a lot of businesses make
right uh is uh you take someone who's a
developer or a producer of content or
ideas and they become they become a
manager instead and sometimes you're not
utilizing that person as well as you
were originally right where maybe
they're even an above average to very
good manager but they were someone who
was top of the charts as a as a inventor
or a Content producer and so you're not
really maximizing their skill set enough
um so and did you find uh when you
joined the times that your reach or
influence immediately changed
um it was it was not like an order of
magnitude shift I think we probably got
um you know maybe uh maybe 50 percent
more traffic which is still pretty
significant right but it depends with
the times the uh the slow days are
actually uh no better than they were at
538 but when you get on on the front
page there when something blows up the
Peaks are a lot are a lot higher is the
big difference so what we're at 538
right before you you moved over to
nytimes.com what kind of page views were
you getting
um so during the election I think on
Election Day itself we got like uh 2008
I should say we got like three million
unique visits but the standard uh during
a kind of regular day leading up to the
campaign was um well I guess I should
say it was always on the steady ramp up
throughout 2008 so it started out where
um where I had some following from Daily
Coast so I think the first day he had
like 500 views which isn't nothing and
then um and then there was some profile
aisle and in Newsweek work out to about
3000 and then uh and then became ten
thousand after Sarah Palin got got
nominated you know the conventions and
the interest really peaked up to a
hundred thousand then up to up to three
million on um on Election Day and then
you have the big fall it would be nice
to have three million page views every
day right uh but that's not gonna happen
most people are are saying and have
lives and so once the election's over
um I'm not sure I agree with you there
but well yeah actually but most people
have other interests apart from uh apart
from politics right apart from campaigns
so um so it has it's a Blog that has
very good and steady traffic
um uh uh but not World bidding traffic
during
um during the non-election part of the
campaign and then goes kind of off the
charts during the election the election
cycle yeah so
um this election cycle certainly your
relationship to the mainstream media
despite having become a part of the
mainstream media
um seemed to be pretty radically
different from what it had been in 2008
a number of people seem to be going out
of their way to pick fights with you or
you had you and Joe Scarborough
got in a little dust up uh which I think
you won fairly handily but but
um but also you know places like
Politico
as the campaign was unfolding were
writing pieces asking whether you were
going to be a one-term celebrity
um uh so my first question about that is
why do you think that is was that just a
case of people wanting to kick the big
guy on the Block down a notch I think
that's I think that's part of it I had
one
Politico reporter who shall remain
nameless but you know tell me I don't
get hired by the time not Dylan buyers
okay Higher by the times they're like uh
I was told by this reporter like oh now
that you're working for the time
somebody can quote you anymore right so
part of it is you have people who are
who are deliberately oh someone at
Politico said now that you're working
for the time so it's deliberate
competition right it's not even a lot of
it is kind of some it's premeditated but
more so we're talking about this earlier
right
um so in 2008 it was
um it was fairly clear for the most part
that Obama was gonna was gonna win right
um to the point that you know uh
even the Press he was trying to report
on polls it's really there are some
counter examples for the McLaughlin
group
um three or four panelists on elections
so now it's a toss if it's too close to
call Monica Crowley from Fox News said
she thinks McCain would win by by half a
point right
um but uh but she still has a job yeah
but in that election it wasn't
controversial to say uh
Obama's gonna win uh kind of easily
right whereas this one was right on that
precipice where on the one hand it
wasn't purely 50 50 and as much as it
was misinterpreted the blog you know we
we couch things in explicitly in
probabilities we were never saying oh
Obama's going to win for sure we were
saying but he is a favorite and he's
enough of a favorite that to describe it
as a as a toss-up is is probably wrong
right
um and for some reason the fact that the
set of facts we were we were working
from were uh were so simple right which
just you know look the polls by the
campaign are pretty accurate if you take
an average of the polls you can do it
our way which adds a little bit of
Finance terms of how much we weight the
polls but any site nuclear politics or
um or you know the Princeton election
Consortium or the five or six different
ways to do it all had we're calling you
know 49 out of 50 states the same anyway
and all them had Obama winning the
Electoral College you can debate about
um how much uncertainty there was around
that but you know I think that was part
of what uh what made the attacks kind of
personal at the end is that you know we
were asserting very simple set of you
know kind of sky is blue two plus two is
four set effects like look you know can
you add up to 270 that's how many votes
you need to win the electoral college
can you take an average of the polls
right well if yes you come to the
conclusion that Obama's ahead right now
you can debate again is that does that
mean he's not likely to win or 55
um but but that's what I think made it
so so personal is uh is there wasn't
this ambiguity you couldn't just get
lost in the weeds and debate the
interpretation so much
um well there also seemed to be
um this confusion among among some of
the people who were critiquing you about
um process and results yeah and having a
a process that essentially is a good
process and is going to more often than
not get you to where you want to be
going
um and always getting the results that
you want or that are predicted from that
process and
um when you uh I guess you bet Joe
Scarborough is that right he didn't
accept the BET actually
which uh sort of showed old and new
um part of it is that uh you know
um
you talk about people being being two
results oriented and and they actually
they certainly are two results oriented
and I think I said before the election
in different venues that like I'll get
too much credit if I'm if we have a good
night on November 6 and too much blame
if I don't
um and you know we had a good night and
I'm getting too much credit right now uh
but the point was in in uh in a literal
sense you know I had uh in terms of kind
of net future earnings discounted
somehow then I had a lot more than than
you know 2 000 bucks or whatever the BET
was right on the line I don't think it's
a bad incentive look in in uh in
business
um you know you want your product to be
successful and there's some some risk
there you can have a good process and uh
and get a bad result or or vice versa
but the idea that you're tying your
incentives to your notion of of
correctly forecasting an outcome you
know why that's objectionable I wasn't
really I wasn't really sure when I
played poker it's honorable to bet to
bet on things right right so I kind of
sympathize with the Mitt Romney like ten
thousand dollar bet I guess I against
Rick Perry in one of the debates where
it's like at some point this guy's
yammering on yammering on it's like okay
well are you you know are you are you do
you believe you're on well then
bet on it right
right but but uh let's say if you had
not gotten all of the state did you get
50 states right this time yeah um so you
called Florida no I yeah I did yeah
okay so I don't think uh
I'm not sure that the 50 out of 50 thing
matters so much this guy in the game
election right like if we had had some
uh some election where we had gotten you
know so for example we had Obama winning
by uh by in a popular vote by two
percent on our election night forecast
they wound up winning by by four percent
instead right so it's almost as big an
error or the same error as if Romney had
won the popular vote by um by one tenth
to the point or something but I don't
think it would have been seen
symmetrically certainly if if Romney had
won by one tenthood you could criticize
that oh Nate you know underestimate
Obama one thing that helped I guess was
fortunate for me is that you had a lot
of states that were uh were just barely
leaning Obama so if Obama beat his polls
he actually did in Most states then um
then you're a little bit off but um but
you don't call the winner wrong whereas
if Romney beat his polls by by a couple
of points he might have won uh uh four
or five states he you know you'd be far
from getting 50 right but so apart from
what the perception would have been in
the public at large
um let's say that you had gotten it
wrong those two percentage points are or
that had gone the other way and it had
gone the other way in enough swing
States so that uh Romney eked out an
electoral college Victory would you then
have
um doubted the formula and doubted the
system that you put together
not not too much because you know uh the
funny thing about the 538 uh formula is
that there's more uncertainty really I
mean in a literal sense when you're
early in the election in June or July
there's more uncertainty because there's
more time for for different events to
intervene but there's also more
structural uncertainty in uh in building
the model where for example we had a way
to account for the economy where we
created an index of economic conditions
and then but there are a lot of ways to
do that or how you weigh and come and
see
um so um so you know but by the time you
get to the end of the campaign you know
all the all the model based approaches
really really converge right where it's
because we weren't saying at that point
it wasn't a complicated model at all I
wasn't trying to balance the economy and
get suppose saying we're just looking at
the polling at this point anything from
the economy should be priced in by now
and it's just an exercise and saying um
how much uncertainty is there and if you
have a a four-point lead in a state or a
three-point lead in the state on
Election Eve with robust polling how
often do you win that state that's a
case where you come closer to there
being like an objectively kind of right
answer whereas earlier it's a more
difficult modeling problem and so you
know I wouldn't have felt too bad if
well I would have felt bad for a lot of
reasons right but um but I don't think I
would have said oh uh I gotta go back
and when you're saying for a lot of
reasons you mean including the fact that
you're an Obama supporter
no I mean for uh mostly I mean believe
me if that the fact that uh that Obama
won the election was like didn't occur
to me until like two days after the fact
I'm like oh good you know I didn't
this up right
um and now it'll be fun to throw
Politico for for a few days uh but no I
mean the fact that the you know I mean
this is probably a bad sign in some ways
right but um but I was working 100 hour
weeks and become so involved in this
kind of psychodrama around what the 538
predictions being also just the fact
that you're making these these forecasts
and blogging and doing a book tour at
the same time right so you become kind
of abstracted from uh from The Real
World of the election even in 2008 we're
actually uh was in the museum in
Washington doing stuff for hdnet on
Election night right where we were doing
coverage until uh until one in the
morning right you kind of say Obama win
you get out and like people are like
whooping hollering around Washington DC
which is a very button downtown ordinary
and only then it actually dawned on me
that oh you had Obama elected president
right so you I mean being in the bubble
is kind of a a real thing I think and
something that maybe
um you know of the other problems I have
with campaign journalism I think you
know the lack of self awareness of how
your perceptions are skewed when uh when
you're in that bubble as a reporter
um when uh you know 75 of the American
public has heard nothing about the
sequester right
um but you know journalists think that
oh you know the way Bob Woodward's
column is interpretable radically shift
public opinion on this stuff and that
can be something you want to avoid right
right
um uh so there are a couple more points
I want to get to before
um we we open it up one is just your
your future
um with the times I just want to read uh
what Jill Abramson the editor uh
executive editor of the time said
recently
um uh so this was from after the
election I guess uh late November she
said
um half the people coming to nytimes.com
searched for Nate they were aren't
coming for the rest of the times they
came for him
she also said that when when asked if
you would get a wing of the building I
think she said that you have your own
Tower
so your contract you signed a three-year
contract in 2010 which comes out this
summer is that right yeah so what do you
see for for your future so I don't have
any any news to break I'm in active
discussions with uh with the times and
and and like I said earlier uh it's a
really great fit in a lot of ways I
think Jill is a terrific terrific Adder
you know I mean anything can happen in a
negotiation but um but you know we'll
see I'm pretty happy there and you know
and and the the best things and the
worst things about working at times are
are for the most part pretty
self-evident right we're where the best
thing is that uh is that you know it's
still uh one of the most trusted brands
in news that make the content look
really good and kind of they left their
people have a fair amount a fair amount
of voice right so you look at someone
like like David Carr for instance their
media columnist you know he has found a
way to uh to have his own voice and
somehow uh have it be in harmony with
the mission of the times brand I think
there are other the other news
organizations that tend to swallow up
their voices and um and that's
problematic now and so knowing uh
knowing that is a definitely a reason to
stay with the time so the negative is
just that you do get a level of um of
scrutiny that I think is deserved in
many cases but also you're talking about
scrutiny
um internally or scrutiny because you're
at the times from the external World
well I think I think the times like any
you know any Newsroom is is often
internally competitive as well as
competitive with with its Rivals but I
mean more in terms of you know everyone
comes after the times like it's the it's
the it's the New York Yankees basically
right and and a lot of people hate the
Yankees right but pay attention to what
the Yankees do potentially
um you know the the the the less obvious
uh
downside of that is that sometimes it's
hard to be kind of uh kind of casual at
the times right where you know with a
Blog sometimes you can kind of say well
um here's an observation you wouldn't
quite phrase it exactly this way but
you'd say here's an observation I have
but I haven't really thought about this
very deeply right I'm just kind of you
know farting around I guess right
um and uh it's hard to do that at times
Authority right but when you say
something that people don't you know
like we got some mini controversy with
Politico the day about uh about the
choice of language I use to describe
activities of super Pacs right it's like
well we don't actually it's not actually
it's just a clarification versus
correction yeah yeah it's actually not
that important in the context for us to
be super precise about the language he
was trying to communicate this other
point to the audience right
um but at the times you can get into
more trouble for for that kind of thing
because people do uh treat it as being
so authoritative which I'm not saying is
a healthy thing necessarily
um but so it's harder to uh Define that
voice but like I said um for people like
myself or like or like David Carr or
some of their Tech columnists or their
Sports columnists they do um is a a
space that cultivates having having many
voices and not just this one disembodied
kind of voice of the New York Times so
that leads into another thing I I wanted
to get to which is
um you mentioned how uh your methodology
is not as transparent as
um it might be in for instance an
academic environment but you're fairly
upfront about what you do we talked a
little bit earlier about how this is
actually not rocket science you have a
bunch of polls and you can put them
together
um so
what is it you think that has made you
so uh so popular is it the voice of the
blog is it the fact that I know you work
for your college paper I've spent a lot
of time at writing is it the fact that
you're not putting these numbers out
there which as you said Real Clear
Politics does a bunch of other sites do
but that you're doing it with voice and
with narrative yeah I mean look I spent
a lot of time uh
you know on my on my writing I just
don't I don't usually put a blog post up
without reading it rereading it four or
five times and and the times encourages
you to think about your uh your Pros um
I spent a lot of time on uh on the
graphical presentations of things we do
and the times interactive journalists
the graphic journalists are are uh this
is not hyperbole they really are like
the best in the world at what they do
um and so that helps a lot the way
you're communicating information I think
um I think a lot of these things we're
talking about are are not really that
complicated right I'm a guy who says
yeah the details do matter and sometimes
I'll get in back and forth with academic
clinical scientists about the nuances of
how do you measure the economy in your
election model etc etc right
um but but you know mainstream funerals
are missing but that's very stuff for
the margins yeah at the margin right
they're missing very basic points and I
think uh sometimes uh when um I don't
know it's a balance because you can also
have cases where where conclusion is
oversimplified so I guess that's kind of
the um the scale in good non-fiction
prose writing about science or or
technology right is uh how do you uh
distill the gist of something without
dumbing it down right um and that does
require some skill and because I wrote
about baseball and uh because I had some
background also as a kind of
pseudo-journalist in in college where I
actually did go and uh why sudo well
that's sudo I guess right we actually go
and track down like they're going to
close down the softball field talk to
them you know so not it's not you know
not as much of it as some people might
have but Chicago yeah yeah right in high
school and and college
um so to have those skills was was
really uh was really helpful
um so I think two more questions uh one
is two more questions for me and then
we'll open it up to um I'll view
um one is do you think that we could um
or are moving towards the type of
predictions that you're that you do at 5
38 being able to apply the methodology
to make those predictions uh about a
broader subset of of issues could that
enter into a sort of scientific
discipline
um the way that political forecasting
has well look there's more interest in
uh in in data science now and kind of
big kind of big data I tend to be uh
suspicious of claims that suggests
there's some massive inflection point
and technological growth I guess I'd say
right so you clearly have meaning what
well so you clearly have an exponential
increase in the amount of of data and
information available to people measured
in a variety of ways um but that's never
been the constraint right the
constraint's not the amount of
information you have but our ability to
come to useful knowledge uh from that
data that yields you know tangible
improvements in technology and and the
economy and everything else right
um and so you know our human constraints
are going to be a much bigger Factor
than this growth of information right
and people also don't realize that
sometimes uh you know you might have a
data set which is large but not
especially Rich necessarily where and
this is probably talk about in the book
but you have problems like like kind of
overfitting as technical name for a
problem where um where your your mining
data from the past
um and claiming it's predicted but
really it's just giving you a very
detailed description version of past
happenings and it may not carry over and
make good predictions as well so my kind
of I mean the book is a survey of uh
basically is Big Data producing con or
progress in the context of prediction
the answer is
um is yes in some cases but as a general
proposition it's slower than you might
expect and and so does that mean that
um you've gotten some criticism uh most
notably I think in a New Yorker blog
post about your Reliance on Bayesian
analysis
um uh am I am I hearing you right and
saying that we there's a place for both
types of analysis well I think so uh
you know what qualifies as as Bayesian
is is kind of a sticky subject where if
you talked about people who are formal
statisticians it means a specific set of
of methods right right um and in my book
I don't usually mean it in in that
technical a way
um you know instead I see it's almost a
series of values
um you know one of the most important of
which is that uh you start from some
base where you do have assumptions and
biases that maybe are are equal to the
wealth of knowledge accumulated up to
that point in time or what the consensus
at that point in time
um and so the alternative where you're
testing a null hypothesis right is kind
of it's kind of arbitrary and that if
you find something which is ciscally
significant uh relative to the test you
set up it doesn't make any sense in the
broader context of of other research you
should be suspicious of that for example
right I see that a lot of of science
journalism for example where sometimes
you know I think there are now something
like 3 three academic papers published
every minute or some ridiculous
statistic like that tens of thousands
every year and sometimes someone that
make the most outrageous conclusion are
the ones that get reported on
oftentimes right and the peer review
process is by not any means perfect but
you do gradually have this synthesis
where someone says no this is you know
the cure for everything and someone says
no it's a cure for it's totally
right then you know eventually there's
some since that's where you move toward
toward the truth you have that process
and I see that as being Bayesian the
idea of kind of updating your beliefs as
you move forward so I think uh you know
I wasn't so you're referring more to a
Bayesian philosophy is about yeah yeah
right so I think you know I think
some of the some of the critiques took
to literally the sense so you should
only apply these particular methods
right where there's maybe a kind of
frequentist technique you can apply in a
Bayesian way right I suppose or maybe
vice versa right right okay
um uh and actually I guess I lied
because there is one more thing I want
to touch on before you open it up and
that's
um you had some strong words for
um the punditocracy
um uh there are
um a number of columnists I think we
probably both have some problems with
um but what I find particularly
frustrating is
columnists who assert things with no
factual basis yeah and then claim that
glad you agree
um uh and then and then claim if you
criticize the fact that they have no
factual basis they say well what they're
doing is exercising their right to voice
their opinion it's just an opinion man
I
yeah that's the wonderful thing about uh
about prediction though is that if
you're making a prediction a true add a
sample prediction not a model that was
fit to pass data then you're actually
putting uh putting your opinion on the
line right you're testing whether your
perceptions have any correspondence to
reality and and um I'm not just being
cheeky I mean you see uh Phil tetlock
was a guy who uh who uh used to work at
Berkeley is now at pan a psychologist
and he studied over 20 years how well
that um the predictions of political
experts do and so that including people
you think of as pundits also
um academics and journalists
um and uh and people on the inside of
politics and found that they weren't
really any better than than random for
the most part right and there were some
exceptions there were people who have
certain personality traits
um what he called uh foxes instead of
hedgehogs who did a little bit better
um but um but the industry has a history
of getting things wrong right what was
kind of amazing too was that you had
people who you know some very very smart
conservatives like George Will and
Michael Barone who were not just
asserting that um oh well it's close and
around nicobene Ohio right but we're
predicting a Romney Landslide and
contradiction to all available evidence
and Peggy Noonan also very smart who's
saying that the fact that she saw Romney
yard signs meant that there was a
Groundswell in the country as a whole
yeah so her you know her neighborhood or
Tony neighborhood in Virginia or
whatever right you know and people if
they're George Tommy this really is like
uh you have a better source so the idea
that she could read the average voter
better than the actual random voters who
were like literally called by the polls
right that's I mean that's the the
pretense behind why um what
organizations like the times sponsor
polls actually is that so you have
reporters who um who report and although
they're going to represent the kind of
expert or Elite consensus you also want
to hear from the men or women on the
street and what better way to do that is
to randomly survey uh random men and
women
do fairly well about under certain
assumptions right people are bad and
polls are bad explaining why people
believe what they do
um and people are bad at predicting
their behavior far in the future but for
the most part if you have someone who
you can vote for tomorrow then they'll
give you a a honest response we know
that empirically right and it's a lot
better than trying to count up the
number of yard signs or something so so
the fact that that Pagan Newton
obviously continues to be employed by
The Wall Street Journal is that is that
um do you think that's indicative of uh
the sort of power of narrative and that
she is a very good writer and and is
superlative writer or is it does that
have more to do with
um the fact that we now can create these
information cocoons and we're getting
more and more used to only consuming the
information that is going to validate
our world view it's it's both and I'm
trying to figure out which of those you
know but I actually think that the
latter concerns so kind of the the story
I tell in in the first book the signal
in the noise is kind of the story about
well our brains are wired to detect
patterns and to build stories around
essentially random data and and that's a
big part of it but I do think these kind
of information feedback loops is it
bigger and bigger element of the story
as well where if you look at the
demographics actually the Wall Street
Journal is an exceptional has a fairly
bipartisan audience um but uh but you
know only five percent of people who
watch uh Sean Hannity on a given night
are Democrats right only two percent
people who watch Rachel Maddow on a
given night are Republicans you really
have people consuming the news in two
different ways one thing I'd like to do
is go back uh and maybe a somewhat
formal way and study which polls were
cited um were cited by the media most
often and when because this seems like a
fairly tangible way to test media bias
right if you um if you have two polls
for example when we relate the campaign
there was a case where you had two polls
came out the same day a in in Minnesota
one of which had Obama of only three
points just think it was in play I want
to chat him up eight right
um and they probably had him up three
points
um showing it competitive was cited like
five or six times more often right the
only reason for that was because you
want to create The Narrative of the
campaign stuff but that's the story bias
right I'm not saying I'm not saying
believe me I'm not saying that the media
has a republican leaning bias believe me
uh but I think it doesn't but that was
that was a bias for a story you have a
bias for for a story right you see this
absolutely in the in the uh in the chair
election campaign but also at the end of
the primary campaign where um where
people were writing you know when Rick
Santorum was was hundreds of delegates
behind and really didn't have a viable
path unless there was some major Scandal
involving around people saying well you
know Romney must win this Illinois
Primary or well or what then he'll only
be 180 delegates ahead right
um you know so the primaries especially
to some extent in in 2008 also with with
Clinton versus
um Obama that was a little closer than
but later
the string a little bit unless you had
some Monumental event occurring then uh
then you know that outcome was was
preordained for the most right right
um all right why don't we open it up we
have two um microphones uh we're gonna
try and keep the questions pretty short
to
um about a minute so that we can ask as
many as possible uh why don't we start
over here
oh yeah and please um please identify uh
yourself
um so we know who to come after
afterwards
um uh when you're at the mic hi uh
thanks very much I'm Ian condry and I'm
a professor here in comparative media
studies uh really enjoy your stuff it's
really interesting my question is about
political reporting and these questions
of objective subjective because I
certainly agree there's a problem with
media bias but I wonder if there's not
also a danger of too much accuracy and
this has sort of been to accuracy and
predictive power I mean one of the
things that's so frustrating I think
about the political campaigns is the
oversimplification of red and blue uh
the emphasis on only the swing States
the undecided voters and then of course
the last minute somehow it's all about
the base that needs to get out and
there's a kind of common narrative but I
wonder if there's a point where you the
predictive power of 538 uh becomes kind
of self-reinforcing right does it really
to a decline in Democratic pressure a
patient because we think it's already
decided I mean certainly in the the red
and blue already decided states that
happens to some extent uh and I think in
some ways because we still didn't trust
you until this election that now it's I
wonder if it changes the dynamic now
that 538 so accurate did so well that
then we do we even need voting and I'm
wondering what's your yeah I hope people
don't uh well that's my question is sort
of in your sort of self-reflexive and
thinking about your role in this what do
you think about that problem
um you know as I've said before if I if
I feel like uh 538's forecasts are
actually influencing voting behavior
then that would be a very dangerous
precedent I think although I would say
uh you know
uh media coverage in general influences
elections especially in in the primaries
for example where where one case for
example in the GOP Primary this year for
some reason the kind of media decided
early on that uh that Gary Johnson was
not a a serious candidate for some
reason even though credential wise he
was someone who had been elected
governor of a swing state twice I think
where some other guy who ran a pizza
company was more entertaining and so I
guess was was determined to be more
viable right but you see the media put
its finger on the scale in a lot of
different ways and to the extent you
have that then I'd rather have uh I
guess I'd rather have accurate
information affecting public sentiment
than inaccurate information but the
other point is that um you know
I'm not someone who always says that oh
everything is uh is super predictable
right and people are just being
bone-headed about it if you read the
book then we say a lot of times in
general more often the opposite error is
made where people overrate how
predictable things are and so um and so
if you see for example when you have a
uh a job support come out where say we
uh we create 20 000 jobs a month we were
supposed to create 90 000 or something
right those types of Errors happen all
the time on average the Miss is about
seventy thousand or eighty thousand jobs
what it's always seen as you know a
catastrophic mistake and people don't
understand how much economic uncertainty
there is for example so um so you know I
mean part of his uh is I think
journalists uh seeing empiricism is kind
of the enemy and and seeing looking at
the work that academics do and and more
technical analysis I think I think
that's more the problem than um than uh
than saying everything is up for grabs
because sometimes the opposite mistake
is made instead so and you did you did
say recently that if in 2014 or 2016 you
saw 538 influencing elections in some
way that you might then step away from
it because that would make you feel
uncomfortable so specifically what what
did you mean how would you see 538
influencing elections
I mean if I think it's probably more of
a risk in say uh individual campaigns
for the U.S house or something where or
one case where uh where in the polls
probably do matter some is in a stage
where you have candidates competing with
another for scarce resources so in the
primaries for example uh Tim polenti's
people uh quit the campaign in
retrospect uh Kim plenty and his people
quit the campaign right in retrospect
they could maybe have two or one who
knows right um
but they felt like they were far behind
enough where uh in the polls where they
were not going to get donations from
from leading Republicans and therefore
they couldn't build out the campaign so
it kind of became a self-fulfilling
prophecy so you have cases like that so
if you have cases for example where
um where you have influential Republican
donors or Democratic donors trying to
figure out which Senate campaign do I
donate to and they go to 538 and they
see that well this campaign the GP
county has a has a 30 chance of winning
they're still very viable I'll give
money to them and not the candy who has
a five percent chance of winning instead
of that kind of that might be a way in
which uh in which the outcome is is
influence potential but why so why would
that I'm not entirely clear on why that
would make you uncomfortable because
isn't that a valid data point for them
to make those well I guess that's the
Counterpoint right is uh is uh you know
look that information is out there and
if you aggregate in a more efficient way
then you shouldn't be be scared of of
having more disclosure basically but
remember you know implicitly models are
are based on the assumption that um I
know I mean there's some kind of
academic questions I guess about uh
about do you have a model which is
premised on the notion that people don't
know what the model says and then this
Behavior like change as a result so one
problem we had for example in in 2010 is
we had um races for individual US House
Seats in 2010 which we didn't do in 2012
we will again in 2014.
um but one of the inputs that that model
was the forecast made by independent
analysts like cook political who have a
very good track record right but we were
basically free writing off them but the
problem is that uh you know I know the
political guys the organizations that do
this they would read 538 and they would
say well you guys at this county has a
90 chance of winning so we're going to
sort of just become upgrade that from
safe uh or from you know leaning
Republican to Safe Republican or
whatever right so you have a feedback
loop right effect instead so we're going
to cut that out of the model in um in
2014 I think you mean cut out that using
things like cook literally so this is a
slightly esoteric point but I think uh
if you build a a forecast model I think
think the metric you should use it's not
solely about solely about how accurate
are you are but it's how much value kind
of do you add so if you have a model
that like basically and there's some
models like this that um that for
example take what intrade says which are
prediction markets and then and then uh
and then slightly tweak that or
something right if you're trying to
gamble on an event then
um then that might be best but you're
probably adding very little value to the
overall public knowledge you're
basically free writing off predictions
that everyone else has made so the
extent that you can cite here is an
approach it's more proprietary right and
here's the value that it adds I think is
is is preferable and so trying to avoid
those uh those feedback loops I think
would be right one small step there yes
hi Nate John Hawkinson electrical
engineering computer science my question
for you it kind of reflects I think what
a lot of people I know uh would want to
ask you and apparently the person
aligned behind me too go figure what are
the chief impediments to open sourcing
your model or or variant of it or
historical version of it because people
want to play to open sourcing them well
first of all it's not that hard to to
reverse engineer it necessarily but you
know I mean you know it's
uh I am very sympathetic to the kind of
academic Viewpoint that science should
be should be open source right but I you
know I don't have a a 10-year track
position
um you know I make money in part from my
ability to license proprietary content
and if you open source something then uh
then you know that value is diminished
but I never I would never
ever rule out that I wouldn't do it you
know one one solution maybe to um if I
do feel like I get bored of this or 538
uh is influencing something too much
it's just to publish the source code and
say now it's in the public domain and go
ahead and and have fun with it but I do
think we can reach a um a a better level
of disclosure where things are more
explicit if you go back to 2008 things
were were fairly explicit about how uh
about uh how we disclose things but we
didn't release the source code we didn't
release the actual database of polls
um but you know I don't know I mean like
I said I'm still taking the point of
view that should be completely open
source but you know I am a it is a
for-profit business and that influences
things well maybe next year we could see
last year's model
last year yeah
well changed all that much from year to
year yeah
yeah
hey Adam Ryan uh political junkies so
that's why I'm here I want to ask you so
um basically in order to forecast you
have to understand the system you're
forecasting for
um and I think kind of your Hallmark
right now is the Electoral College
um and you've kind of voiced I think
pretty clearly that you're opposed to it
that you think probably a direct PR a
direct vote would be better a popular
vote and that's great in terms of I mean
I think it's a pretty simple explanation
for unitary executive I'm wondering for
Congressional and parliamentary systems
if you have an opinion on what might be
a better way for elections to work like
there's because there's a lot of debate
in that theory whether like an AV an AV
plus mixed PR stuff like that the way
systems could be used for Congressional
and representative elections if you have
an opinion on what might be best I mean
the funny thing is that the uh
in some ways the Senate is otter in that
you have as many senators in California
as you do in Wyoming but you're actually
getting more of a skew now in the House
of Representatives now the Senate uh uh
or the Electoral College because you
have Democrats concentrate in big cities
like like Boston and Chicago you just
wrote about this in the last day or two
yeah yeah and in some ways the fact that
you know so so States happen to work out
fairly well where um where Most states
have a combination of urban areas and
rural areas but congressional districts
where you really are packing Democrats
in or shouldn't use the active voice
unnecessarily um where Democrats are
kind of pecking themselves into big
cities now
sometimes abetted by by gerrymandering
and States Republicans control the
process but um but yeah that has
interesting implications where um where
this Urban rural divide
um you know the the Constitution kind of
part by excellent part by Design tends
to give slightly more voice to rural
areas relatively speaking
um you know people talk to you about
what other Republicans had a
disadvantage in the race of the
presidency well well maybe but also
doing well in rural areas that means
they are going to always do well on the
race for the house for example so trying
if the party's trying to optimize its
overall political Fortune there might be
kind of a a quasi-stable equilibrium
where Democrats do have an edge in the
presidency but the price for that is
that in midterms where you have
um voting groups like young voters and
Hispanics Africans are less likely to
turn out
um where the the way District structure
tends to favor rural areas a bit more
you'll kind of have you know maybe we'll
have a Democratic president a republican
house for for a very long time so so get
used to the current gridlock I suppose
um I'm just a student here but I was
wondering you were talking earlier about
the issue of pondicherry in the media
um and also about the issue of feedback
loops and just like what thoughts you
have on the the media's ability to fix
that problem since people do pay for the
media that they want to receive and they
want to hear the things they want to
hear
so it's um
it's a difficult problem and you know
one thing I've been thinking about is
it's fun to uh
to critique individual journalists who
kind of are are doing things in kind of
a silly way but um but you know their
self-interest is often in providing
coverage that's sensationalistic right
um and so no I'm in a position now where
like I've uh I work for the times and I
publish the book and you know have
enough income now where I can say well I
can be magnanimous and kind of seek
after truth and I always have done that
throughout my career but it's easier to
do that when um when you have the the
luxury of doing that instead of someone
who's who's struggling to make a name
for themselves
um and uh and uh and you know publishes
some link bait
um that's trolling Nate silver or
something as a result or the typing up
less than that it's hyping up the result
of some poll because they have to meet a
quota for how much traffic they get and
I don't necessarily have a good sense
for how to to solve those problems I do
think and maybe this is a romantic idea
that um that sometimes journalists uh or
news organizations think too much about
how many pages something get in the
short term as opposed to what's it say
about your brand uh in in the longer
term right um that when you link to
something that's stupid then
um then there are two things that
happens number one is that uh number one
is that you're hurting your brand and
long term number two is that it's easy
to compete with stupid right um you know
anyone can uh can link to someone else's
articles and do this kind of cheap
little value-add aggregation right
um and so you know you're not going to
have a an advantage in that department
for a very long time and so um so how
can you be differentiating is the
question I would ask but but for people
who are kind of engaged in the career
being a a political reporter or
something it's it's it's it's more
difficult potentially I think you have
to have look more at the organizational
level in terms of of what values does
the organization have and how are they
incentivizing their people and do they
care about their their brand and do you
think that there's any possibility that
news consumers will start to
um play a more active role I I I I and I
guess this is my sense of things and not
based on actually any data but my sense
is that as consumers we're still
functioning as we were 20 years ago so
sort of assuming that there are these
big media conglomerates that essentially
are working on similar stories and have
similar story lines where that's
obviously not true and it seems like we
have a ways to go before
the the active intelligence of news
consumers kind of catches up to their
influence in the process well I mean
part of what I do resent about um
about for example Politico is that they
do treat the uh the readers being an
idiot a lot of the time
um you know I think uh I think look not
everyone's going to want the kind of
wonky nerdy coverage meaning what
meaning that they don't uh you know they
they think that people are gonna um
you know don't see the forest for the
trees basically right
um and I think that uh that if they say
well you know the race is rapidly
shifting that people are just going to
buy that and not have their own their
own scrutiny of it necessarily and very
often throughout the campaign you saw it
um events so for example uh people
remember after the uh the attacks in in
Benghazi which is now seen as uh as a
failure on the part of the White House
right but there was this kind of very
arbitrary media consensus that um that
Mitt Romney's reaction to Benghazi was a
big story would really hurt him in a
campaign and it didn't really move the
polls very much at all right
um but you know I think I think the news
media tends to have an overly simplistic
view of how of how voters think about
elections where voters might not think
about exactly like like someone in the
Beltway establishment might but they do
have their own way people think about
presidential elections pretty carefully
where for example the heuristic that
people use to measure economic growth is
is arguably pretty sophisticated where
it's not just um oh how good is economy
right right now but if you're looking at
is the economy getting better or worse
and I'm going to look at it relative to
Baseline of a couple years ago and and
not over the longer term because that's
a way to assign more credit or blame to
to the incumbent right right and so you
had a case like this year where the
unemployment was uh was you know eight
percent election day or also in 1984 it
was seven and a half percent where you
had incumbents and Ronald Reagan's case
a landslide but elected easily and then
not so easily but clearly enough because
you had economic progress being made um
or some reports like oh economy bad
voters tossed out incumbent it's like no
actually people are like a little bit
more sophisticated than that if you read
the political science on it then it
describes what what should have occurred
but Politico is is actually
um from a from a financial standpoint I
would I would argue a journalistic
success story over the last you know
five years
I you know I don't know much about their
their finances all right I mean look
there's going to be a market for uh for
certain things and one one secret about
being a a uh a um
a rag I guess targeted toward Beltway
insiders is that um is that it's very
advantageous to reach that crowd with
lobbying money in essence so if you have
sites that are targeted for inside
audiences you can make incredible cpms
um by you know running ads for Clean
Coal or whatever else cpm's being uh
being how much you get per out of
pressure right right by or something
higher than reading it to a general
audience because you are literally
reaching uh congressman and and centers
and staffers on the hill and people who
are peddling influence in different ways
right um so there is definitely a market
for an Insider audience right that can
that can sustain a certain number of
reporting organizations you know I
happen to think that um that kind of the
traditional ones like like roll call and
the National Journal and stuff do a
somewhat better job with the reporting
than Politico does for example
um but um but that's certainly a market
Niche and I do think that um this demand
for for a data driven coverage or you
know kind of wonky political journalism
is also a market Niche right I think
it's not going to ever displace Peggy
Noonan terribly but I think it might be
that it's something that 20 of consumers
want
um and it represents five percent of the
coverage and so right now you still have
things like uh where I think people like
me are in demand you're probably see an
increase until I reaches the equilibrium
and maybe kind of goes over it in some
sense right like in baseball for example
I feel as though um there are plenty of
of stat heads providing very very good
analysis right so there's no more
low-hanging fruit as far as we have a
more quantitatively flavored coverage
right the Market's pretty saturated at
this point right right so at I'm not in
the prediction game but I'm going to go
out in a limb and say that Politico is
not one of the news organizations that
you're in negotiations with
joke I was thinking about like right
um yes
I'm Charles I'm just a Lobby undergrad
um and I was actually worried that the
guy in front of me stole my question but
thankfully he went a different direction
um basically what I was wondering is
this whatever your personal opinions
about the electoral college versus
National popular vote
would you say that you have something of
a vested interest in or keeping it just
because uh it makes the minutiae of
State polling so much more relevant and
it gives you so much more material so I
mean the Electoral College is like a
super interesting modeling problem
actually
um where so the two assumptions that are
clearly false are to assume that uh you
don't want something every state is
independent from the next one clearly
when uh when you had for example this is
very easy to perceive when you had Obama
search after the Democratic Convention
he moved up by by about the same amount
in every state when you had when you had
Romney starts after the first debate
um about the same amount in every state
a little bit of difference around the
margin right but um but how do you
strike that balance between assuming the
outcomes are perfectly correlated versus
perfectly independent that's an
interesting Challenge and that's kind of
one of the things that uh that you know
it would be worth like getting into
technical debates about because I think
we had a pretty good um although too
complicated in a forum but kind of
methodology for that so it's definitely
more interesting thing in that sense it
adds a layer of intrigue to it so for
purely selfish reasons yeah in the name
of the site 538 space number of votes in
electoral college right so uh you know
we had a situation a couple years ago
where uh where when Democrats controlled
Congress they almost gave DC a seat in
the house it would have been screwed I
know yeah but fortunately for me you
know the NRA somehow tied this building
a bill on gun control and so it got
stymied in committee and so you know 539
is much less mellifluous than 5 30. I
think so it would have been uh and
someone else had already registered it
instead so
so I'm really against uh in a selfish
way against you know Puerto Rico gaining
have you now gone and registered 540 and
541 oh it's too late now in fact it was
quite I mean every number spelled out
written from zero to like 6 000 or
something is now which is now taken
right
and uh if I'm allowed to do like a quick
follow-up yeah um
on very similar lines
if we sometimes move to a national
popular vote whether by interstate
compact or somehow Constitutional
Amendment uh Beyond just changing the
name
what would you do if 538 is still added
by that time I mean you'd still do
forecast one uh one point we tried to
make uh during uh this last campaign is
that even absent the Electoral College
that that state polls provide a lot of
information about where the national
popular vote is we can you know if you
want to estimate what will the National
popular vote be there two ways you can
just say well average the national polls
or the other approaches to uh it's just
you know roughly how many voters vote in
every state than average each state poll
and add that together it turns out that
second approach actually seems to work a
bit better in part because you have more
more data points so that's a case we're
actually doing a bit more work you know
in general I think one theme about
modeling is that you know you get very
Dimension returns to adding complexity
to your model that's a case where where
you have enough the data is more robust
if you're averaging from the individual
states and so it could have still been
useful in some ways but it'd be it would
definitely be
um be less interesting as a modeling
problem I suppose
yes hi Nate my name is Michael stepner
I'm a research assistant who does work
with big data doing economic research
and my question is this it seems like
you have uh the presidential prediction
model down pat you're doing pretty well
at it and looking at your career it
seems like you enjoy building models so
I guess my question is what do you see
as your future in terms of Technical
Innovations is it kind of improving uh
your existing models is it building new
political models or going in New
Directions
uh well not secret but we were talking
before about a history of kind of once I
get bored of doing things every four
years and kind of Veer off in an
unpredictable Direction uh you know one
area that I find interesting so I did a
project for uh
for for New York Magazine in 2010 where
we rated uh different neighborhoods and
of course it's a magazine sleep they
want some objective answer which is the
best neighborhood but my whole point was
that well you get to weigh the factors
that you want that you find a
neighborhood that's a comparative
advantage relative to your price point
but but you know Urban data for lack of
a better term
um data about cities is another case
where you have a data set that's that's
somewhat rich but it's maybe not being
used all that well and so you could kind
of strike that that middle ground
potentially but yeah I definitely will
get uh you know it's fun to to kind of
be more abstract and and write and talk
about this stuff but at some point I'm
sure I'll have the temptation to go uh
delve into a big new data set because
that modeling is is a lot of fun right
um when it's a fresh problem and you're
not just kind of making improvements
around the the margin
turns out that 539 540 541 and 542 are
also all taken as Twitter handles yeah
yeah
at 43 however is available
um yes hi Nate uh Sunny sidhu I'm a
graduate student in the comparative
media studies program just wanted to
thank you and and you Seth for it's been
a really great discussion
um so my question actually has to do
with I think that it's really clear now
that there's a lot to be gained from
taking a data driven and model informed
approach to political campaigns I'm
wondering do you see much of a a room to
grow in terms of applying that approach
to policy and to governance rather than
just the horse race coverage of
political campaigns and so I think in
the same way that it's just more
productive and insightful and fun to
talk about baseball when you talk about
wins above replacement and not feeling
percentage and wins and losses uh it I
think that there's some debates that
could be richer in this country if we
moved away from sort of misleading and
reductive approaches to data so for
example we've got this makers versus
takers debate that's going nowhere
because it's informed by this really
silly model that you know if you
subtract somebody's social program
benefits from their federal tax payments
then you can tell whether they're a
maker or a taker so what I'm wondering
is
why don't we have a better way of
talking about these issues do we need
something again to like a bureau of
advanced Labor Statistics are there
people in government doing this good
work and people just aren't talking
about well if you if people in um and I
live in New York but if you do talk to
people in the treasury Department for
example they're actually pretty darn
sophisticated about somebody else
they're doing but it's different when
you have to communicate that to to the
public I think um but you know you do
have for example the work that uh that
Ezra Klein does at the Washington Post
in some way is a model of that or it's a
more data driven driven approach to
things in some of the economics bloggers
I find myself actually doing
um a little bit less of that in part
because uh other people do it do it well
but I do think it becomes uh
trickier we have these problems that are
more open-ended
um you know so I guess it is kind of a
you know polling is a simple set of
facts like I've said
um and so you can kind of work with it
and say look if you're not getting you
can't take the average you're getting
that wrong then you're demonstrably
being an idiot at this point right
um but other things like you know what
will the effect of
um Obamacare be on the Health Care
system is a more it's you know it's very
good to have the data driven approaches
but it's a more complicated set of facts
but some way it's a cop-out for me to
say here's a field where it's easy to do
this stuff there's not as much ambiguity
and I'll let um let Ezra everyone else
do the tough stuff instead but there's
no doubt that I mean that would be
really valuable I think it's probably a
little bit
uh optimistic to assume that that's what
people are really interested in I think
there's a market for um for our dad
driven College of Elections because it
seems like it's actually telling you
more the essence of something than than
you would have gotten before
um but you know it's hard I think to
separate out uh your your partisan
desires maybe from your analysis if
you're in if you're in the policy Arena
because the set of facts are more are
more ambiguous potentially
um but you know in some ways also you do
have good debates about some of these
Topics in uh in academic circles and I'm
someone who you know I try and read
academic journals as well as the Wall
Street Journal I guess and um and their
blogs like the monkey cage for example
that are trying to take academic
political science and and interpret it
in ways that the journalists are going
to read I very much support uh support
those efforts as well
yeah hi my name is Ethan Wolfman and I'm
a journalist for USA Today I uh you know
you said earlier people love to build
kind of stories from very scant data and
find patterns in this stuff how do we
make sure that our politicians don't do
this and why does this happen and if I
can rephrase the question or do you have
any interest in politics
well of course politicians build
from from limited supporting
evidence yeah I think one of the uh one
thing that's maybe under remarked upon
is is how um the professionalization of
politics which is not anything new but
has been happening for for a long time
um but the average tenure now of a
senator or a congress uh person is as
long as the Supreme Court Justice
um where it's like 18 years or something
on average
um and you've had people who have become
more and more sophisticated in in
manipulating public opinion I suppose
that's kind of the downside I guess to
to Big Data where on the one hand you
can you can say well uh this voted
targeting stuff that uh that Obama did
is is really admirable from the
standpoint of of you know solving a
difficult data challenge but it's also
kind of creepy maybe potentially too
where they know that much about you
based on your name and and you know kind
of what websites you're looking at and
and whatever else and so I think there
is a real downside to that where maybe
politics has become kind of too um too
efficient for its own good where they're
very good at kind of optimizing their
actions relative to voter opinion and
the near Terminus result
um long-term problems become more and
more neglected people are better about
realizing what do I have to do to get
reelected every two years or four years
or six years and you know that might
have uh negative externalities I guess
for for the rest of society but is it is
it possible that as the
professionalization of politics
um gets codified even more that voters
then will start to realize the effects
of going after those short-term payoffs
and we'll start to develop a longer term
View
uh I mean could potentially I mean this
is a very this is a very kind of uh you
know David brixian yeah
we should just stop things right there
then but if some County gets up and and
you know and uh and says well let's you
know build a a policy based on
sustainability about the the national
debt and about the uh the environment in
America's place the world I mean that's
very compelling to me right um but but I
don't know I mean you haven't really
seen it I don't think either party has
been very uh courageous I suppose right
um but uh you know so you may have Chris
Christie for example who is disinvited
from this from CPAC from CPAC for
instance I mean that's one of the ironic
things is Chris Christie's a guy who um
probably right now second most popular
active politician in America after after
Hillary Clinton that's pretty close um
but probably can't get his party's
nomination you know
um and that's and you seem you seem to
think that he that you don't place a lot
of stock and independent campaigns for
president but you seem to I think it is
a possibility if he decided early on
that he wanted to do it and he has some
first of all again so to have someone
who is that that popular but couldn't
get nominus a fairly rare overlap
um but you know he's also in the in the
New York New Jersey Mega region and so
you know you're going to have access to
people so you probably would need I
think
um Financial backing whether you like it
or not right you probably want a Super
PAC to back you
um so I mean you know it's not
impossible so I know the history of this
is always kind of the journalist pipe
dream of having an independent candidate
or a another three-way election like you
had in 92 but it does seem like um if he
decided today that I want to run a
serious third uh party candidates for
the presidency in 2016 then he'd have a
shot at winning right
um maybe not as good as as it might seem
but you know it's it's a viable path and
at some point I'm becoming a more viable
path for him than than trying to win the
Republican primary right well certainly
right now it seems like there's I mean
not getting invited to CPAC is is not
yeah I mean the thing is he really is
this is part of the point of the column
is that he you know he really is a
moderate on on quite a few issues mostly
we know I've written this a couple times
versions of it and you've had you know
Democrats push back and say well he's
not about he's not you know conservative
on these and that issues well yeah
that's how it works right he on some
issues he's right he's centered or
Center left on on some something more if
you sees right or or center right but
it's actually what a moderate
governorship would a republican would
look like like nowadays and so um so you
know this question well wasn't didn't
Romney govern as a moderate here in
Massachusetts and he he did but you know
one thing about Romney is that Romney
was always pretty um it was kind of
interesting experiment in in what
happened if you had no long-term
consistency at all in your policies
right like maybe it's a dual equilibrium
situation you should either be really
consistent or not consistent at all Rex
and there's no cost anymore to being
able to flip-flop or when people already
have priced that in right right whereas
Christie's brand is more he's someone
who speaks his mine and has a lot of
integrity and so ironically there's more
of a cost uh for him to flip-flop later
on and cater to the Republican base
because he has reputation for for not
doing so right
which side we're here yeah hi uh I'm
Jack leverson I'm a grad student in the
financial economics program
um I was wondering Nate uh as more young
people have cell phones and not
landlines
um how well you think traditional phone
polling is going to be able to adjust
for those changes and whether
um online polling or something else is
going to supplant it in the future I
think Pauline has already built that in
yeah so so most of the uh the New York
Times poll and the NBC poll most of the
credible
mainstream media polls do include cell
phones
um you know the rasmussens and public
policy pollings the world do not and
they by and large did not do very well
um and do you wait the due weight polls
that include cell phone surveys
differently yeah so uh so it's part of
the secret sauce well it's it's
disclosed somewhere right but the rest
of waiting so one thing we do is we
adjust uh we calculate pulster house
effects which is kind of what does the
average pollster say right and if you
have a poll who's consistently uh two
points more Republican leaning and the
average just kind of take those two
points back out
um but the question is what do you mean
by by average it's not actually the
average but it's an average which is
weighted based on on different criteria
how well the pulse was doing in the long
term and that that consensus only uses
uh telephone poles that include cell
phones right so you're looking at how do
these polls compare relative to
um to these kind of Premium polls that
are expensive and and that's where you
adjust everything else too so that's
where you have an implicit cell phone
adjustment but you actually did have a
number of polls that were conducted
online
um this past year that actually did
better than anything else
um and if you look at the graph better
than any of the telephone boiling better
than I mean the telephone calling that
included cell phones was was fairly good
for the most part but the online polls
were almost early accurate in a number
of cases um and so if you kind of look
at the graph of what's
um internet penetration versus what is
landline penetration right well you know
that those wires crossed
um a couple of years ago
um so I I would think the equilibrium
that you might have in the long term
um is that you'll have uh instead of
having these Robo poles like Rasmussen
and PPP you'll have you'll still have a
role for expensive traditional telephone
polling and you'll get more and more
expenses they have to call more cell
phones and you'll have that supplemented
by by kind of cheap internet online
polls instead although one issue also is
that uh is that um you know sometimes
you say well for example these Robo
poles that are using automated scripts
they had a bad 2012 they haven't done
that badly over the long run but there's
some evidence that they actually
calibrate themselves off the good poles
so they're uh so they're free riding
right a bit so that's another issue
where we have to probably introduce some
assumptions about what's going to lead
to better pole quality in the long term
when you're weighing polls and not just
assume that you can't be purely results
oriented right about that for that free
running reason right yes hi Nate uh my
name is Nick I'm a big fan of yours
going back to the BP days so it's been
great to see all the mainstream success
um I remember when pakoda frozen
mainstream I thought yeah
um when pakota first started out it's um
it pretty it outperformed the other
projection systems pretty handily
um and as time went by the Gap is kind
of closed and a lot of the the
Innovations of pakota are now being used
in other systems you know Zips we'll use
percentile forecasts and comparable
players
um and to be fair a lot of that happens
after you left pakota but the Gap is you
know they're they're all pretty much the
same now so I was wondering if you worry
about a similar thing happening to 538
that the other guys will start to catch
on I've heard it said that next election
every media Outlet is going to have
their own Nate silver and so I wonder if
you know it'll be you know where is your
place and oh sure no you're gonna and
this is why you know maybe I'll get into
neighborhood prediction instead of but
uh but there's no doubt that uh that
you're going to have people who are who
are uh who are catching up and they
already were like a number of models
that were that were that were pretty
good right that were had 98 of the same
DNA is as the 538 model did and when you
say 98 of the same DNA you mean the
results tracked 98 of their time the
results were similar but also because
the process for evaluating data was the
methodology the methodology was was you
know even just kind of taking a
um you know if you look at as you add
complexity to a model how the accuracy
tracks right you do encounter
diminishing returns pretty quickly right
right where there's some Maximum hacker
you can even you can even be
intrinsically
um and you know I think the 538 model
does a lot of things well if I thought I
did it wrong if I thought someone else
had a better approach then I duplicate
it myself right
um but um but you're talking about
fairly marginal differences you did see
that with with Dakota and so really it's
like look um if I'm competing against uh
you know the Bloomberg model The
Washington Post model and everyone
else's model then it's not going to do
that much better over the long term
which is you know why I like this
confrontation against the kind of
mainstream pundits who are just terrible
at what they do it's really it's very
easy to be really bad at things right
it's a less than a poker player right
it's really easy to be incredibly bad at
poker right and you can be really really
dumb if you're on the McLaughlin group
every week but it's hard to be that much
better than other people um so no but it
is you have a vested interest in bad
pundits keeping their jobs well it is
and it's another poker player thing
right but uh right but you'd have some
local players who'd always would always
kind of berate the fish right like why
don't you play that hand that way you
know you didn't have the odd straw
you're flush it's like well you make
money from that and long term when
people are making decisions badly so I
should probably be really nice to
Politico right and stuff if they go out
of business then it's gonna the
competition's gonna get tougher and yeah
um well you know that relates a little
bit to it's now uh 30 years since since
Bill James introduced um say brand saber
metric analysis to baseball he's still
extremely popular and and still does a
lot of writing not because what he's
doing is unique but because of his voice
and his and and The Narrative that he
brings to the data that he analyzes and
I think that's I mean Bill James is is
kind of the hero of mine that's great I
you know the one thing I do worry about
sometimes is that uh is that if I am in
myself my voice something it'll be seen
now is as as like two authoritative
right he talked about this problem a
little bit before where with the times
it's such a it gets echoed so much it's
hard to kind of whisper something
quietly and say oh here's kind of an
interesting thing I found in the data
right it gets blown off and magnified in
ways that it's not intended sometimes
um so with some of this Buzz that's
surrounded what 538 did in 2012 and I
worry it's kind of hard to kind of
tiptoe into something more when that's a
lot of the way so if we see another a
new really interesting blog that's
applying statistical analysis to
something and written by Chili Pepper we
should wonder what you're up to maybe
yeah yeah yeah right but you should pay
more attention to people who are who are
innovating in in different ways uh you
know I mean that really is that people
talk about what's the kind of
the Money Ball approach people like oh
it's about you know you favor on base
percentage versus batting average and no
really it's about that you you innovate
relative to
um to where the conventional wisdom is
well and actually I mean the the the the
misinterpretation of Moneyball as being
on base percentage is really important
led to on base percentage being
overvalued oh yeah and you saw shifts
where there was one year where the uh
where Billy Bean talk when they used
drafted like a ton of high school
pictures right because equilibrium had
shifted so much and so I guess that is
kind of where you um you know I've
talked before about how 538 involves an
element of media criticism but to be
competitive you kind of have to have a
sense for what your competition is doing
including kind of what they're what
they're doing wrong and they're
definitely cases where um where I found
people are are acting much too certain
about an election outcome people are
putting too much faith in in models so
um but no I expect that space to get a
lot more competitive and like I said you
had a number of um of very good models
already in 2012 that were doing doing uh
98 of what 538 was doing in some cases
were just as successful right
um I think we'll take a couple of more
questions and and and then probably wrap
things up and uh and they will be out in
the lobby
um selling books oh okay Nate will not
be out in the lobby
um uh Nate will stay here and the so
they should buy the books out there and
then bring them here okay
okay most are gone so if you didn't get
one already too late
um yes uh hi my name is John Truelove I
am an MIT spouse and Big Data geek so my
question is I guess in kind of the story
you told about your career is you kind
of had these Hobbies or interests that
you kind of identified as being
low-hanging fruit for kind of rigorous
analysis but obviously you know it's
it's not just that you kind of
haphazardly you know fell into them you
know there are some characteristics that
you that you identified that these had
so I was wondering if you could kind of
maybe describe the way you were able to
identify these areas that kind of
rigorous analysis could greatly improve
them and maybe if you know some examples
well you do kind of have this chicken
and egg thing where you become curious
about something is that because of the
kind of data environment it presents or
because you're just kind of a baseball
fan then then that flows from that but
yeah I mean I'm looking for areas that
have um
kind of a medium level of predictability
and a medium level of data quality sort
of where um where you know the problems
where everything you know so for example
many years ago it was problematic to
predict the orbits of of planets right
where some calculations had Jupiter
crashing into Saturn every 50 years or
something and now that problem is is
solved we don't even think of it as
being a a prediction if you see a title
table it's technically a prediction of
When the tide will uh will Peak or when
the sunrise in the sunset is right but
um but it's so precise we think of it as
being absolute uh fact now right and so
that kind of thing is uh is not that is
not that interesting because it's kind
of been been solved right then you have
problems like uh you know
um like trying to improve on the margin
on on economic forecasts I think we
we're probably people have tried to do
that for a very long time and you
probably uh encounter diminishing
returns I think I think very quickly so
cases where where for whatever reason
the culture has been uh against using
metrics the reason why uh why I say well
maybe maybe cities are an interesting
case and point is because you have
um oftentimes you know Urban
bureaucracies that um they're probably
not taking a very data-driven approach
to things there's a lot of low-hanging
fruit potentially or education uh might
be another area where you see more
attempts to be quantitative and
evaluating teachers and students but I
have no idea whether those are are are
productive and smartly applied or not
um so yeah it's a combination of looking
for things where you have this medium
level of predictability so it's kind of
fun still there are challenges to be
solved but also that the Market's doing
a bad job by by comparison
I'm Michael Chen The Freshman here as
you've moved from saving metrics into
election forecasting at its space you're
still analyzing lots of data but what
are some of the most surprising
differences between the two fields
um you know I think you get more more
betrayal from from political people than
from from a sports people where the good
thing about about uh and and when you
say from political peoples Plus Sports
people are you talking about
um uh people involved in politics for
and people involved in schools
you did have political journalists who
were uh who were kind of anti-stat heads
so I mean maybe you have that same uh
problem within the industry I suppose
but um but I do mean that well first of
all people in sports unless they're Skip
Bayless or something like don't take
themselves quite as seriously I don't
think right or anybody
yeah yeah yeah uh but you know people I
think have a sense of humor about it at
the end of the day whereas political
people take themselves so seriously a
lot of time and have no uh well the
stakes are higher
well the stakes are higher but not
necessarily in you know there's not much
again I'll just keep crawling Politico
for for fun right but the stakes in in
you know whether the email to Bob
Woodward was correctly characterized as
a threat or as a pressure or whatever
there are no Stakes at all right
um and there's not much sense of
perspective in uh in politics about and
political news coverage about is the
story important or isn't it important
right right too much play-by-play I
guess almost
um what was the original question I
guess
I'll just talk about like some of the
most surprising things you've
experienced in this new area of
forecasting yeah but you know when you
don't have when you only have an
election every four years or something
and it's more it's more it's more
difficult certainly um although you
can't see you have you know midterm
elections and other ways to test to test
yourself but um but that's part is you
had actually in uh in baseball this kind
of money by Revolution happened really
pretty quickly where you went um where
you went from in 2002 the kind of period
Michael Lewis was describing where you
had the stat head was kind of locked in
a in a closet with some Cheetos or
something right an internet connection
to where it kind of teams are are having
stat heads run their front offices now
including um you know MIT graduates and
and so forth and so that happened very
quickly but but in sports you have this
thing where where it's very competitive
you have a fairly objective way to um to
test success and failure of course
there's definitely luck involved in
sports but um but that combination is
actually quite rare um so the Moneyball
story is more an exception than the rule
where you have the combination if things
were done badly for a long time
beforehand and you have good ways to
incentivize and measure success you had
very quick progress in that field where
you might not in in other domains as
much
so one one a question that has come in a
couple of times from um from outside of
this room uh I think among science
writers and science communicators
um there's a fair amount of uh thought
slash anxiety about the best way we can
reach the public
um are there lessons from what you do
and the success you've been able to have
that science writers can take away in in
terms of how we can use statistics or
statistical analysis to communicate the
stories that we're trying to tell more
effectively
I spoke earlier about having a lot of uh
having a lot of respect for
um for the reader right
um and assuming that uh you know if
you're not communicating something to to
the reader
um then it's often it's often your fault
right I think also if you have trouble
communicating something effectively
unless very abstract stuff like one on
physics or whatever I'll give give a
pass to that please right but if you're
having trouble articulating what an
argument is right then um then you know
maybe it's not a very good argument to
begin with and so going through the
process of of writing and paying
attention to your writing is is
important
um you know I think I think uh
one thing that helps me a lot is uh
someone who's actually been kind of uh
somewhere between being a practitioner
where you're building models working
with data and kind of a journalist and
you're you're some of both I mean that
that's even your sum of both yeah
exactly right that skill set is kind of
it's kind of because of my odd
background but it that helps a lot I
think
um and it also means that when I talk to
like scientists for um for my book for
example I can I can talk to them um a
little bit more as a as a peer and I
think that you can communicate and of
course believe me there are plenty of
things that go over uh that go over my
head right but but still you can have
more of a conversation about okay tell
me about how you're actually kind of
playing with with this data and what
challenges you face and there should be
I think a lot more science journalism
but um but you know I think having the
you know beginning with the inherent
skepticism about you know here's some
big splashy conclusion that goes against
conventional wisdom well as a default
you should be skeptical that conclusion
right
um and you know but it's not necessarily
what uh what sells books and so forth
and does anything sell books going on a
Daily Show sells books I see I I've been
on The Daily Show and it did not sell my
book
um uh but it's tough you know you know
all these different formats books and
newspapers and magazines have different
have different issues right
but I know at some level you just have
to you know this is where I talk about
the importance of of kind of uh branding
in the long term but if you're someone
who who readers so you do have a
relationship where you can develop or
excuse me you have the opportunity to
develop credibility in a relationship
with the readers over the long term
right and if you're someone who who is
seen as uh as trying to get things right
then I think I think that does count for
something in in the long term right I
hope so yes all right Chris Tam here I'm
an undergraduate uh earlier you were
discussing digital journalism and how
the New York Times
this is expertise in that area kind of
Drew you toward them uh could you
elaborate on both your experience and
what Innovations you see or would like
to see that sort of separate an
individual paper or person from their
competitors
well I mean there are a few things here
and I probably referred a couple of
these in uh in passing but you know
number one is that uh
the visual presentation of materials at
times is really outstanding where if
there were a Pulitzer for uh for graphic
journalism they would have been pretty
much pretty much every year I think it's
the most underrated part of their
operation yeah actually and it's super
incredible it's super important
especially when you're taking and you
know and the thing about uh about the
digital Journal is the reason why um why
they insist and I insist on calling them
you know journalists because they
understand that part of what you're
doing is taking complex information and
figuring out a way to convey uh the
essence of an information in a way
that's that's accurate you're telling a
story with data you're telling a story
with data
um and you know and sometimes they'll
build things in a way that there's one
way to look at it but you can interact
and play around with it
um as a reader in different ways and and
uncover more complexity and in some ways
I think it's a good model even for
um for written content right where you
want to make sure that the um if the
basic storyline you're telling is true
that if someone just gets uh it's just
reading article skimming it and coming
with one thought that the kind of
elevator pitch they're getting is true
but also provide enough detail kind of
in in the footnotes or the links or the
discussion at the end or the references
to other pieces that um that you know
people who want a richer experience can
also get that as well so they they do
that very well I think they do uh very
good about taking a
digital first mentality in the event of
of breaking news so when the pope
announced that he was resigning for
example
um the front page the times had the
Twitter feed from the times Rome bureau
chief right because they realized that
was the best way to communicate things
um in a breaking news context instead of
waiting for someone to file a story um
so that's something I've been doing the
front page of the times is home page not
not yeah not the New York Times yeah you
find it she had like a big Twitter feed
like on the print edition right uh but
but the the web is seen as as leading
the apprenticeship now and they've
gotten away from doing things where
we're going to hold there are some
exceptions but we're not gonna
hold the story
um online until the prediction comes out
it's usually usually
um and the third like I said before is
uh is you know people do have their
individual Brands within the times and
that seems to be very important where
one um one unfortunate reality I think
that I've discovered looking at looking
at traffic at 538 and at um at baseball
perspectives is that you know you really
do people do follow
um individual writers more than they
follow the kind of umbrella of the brand
you can get some Synergy it's not zero
but you have to make sure that your
individual contributors are really
talented and looked after and they tend
to do a good job of a lot of people to
have um to have voice even though you
operate without with a lot of editorial
constraints relative to being a blogger
on your own
um to have a strong Pro style and to
trust their writers to uh to get the
story right in the end and to be fair in
the end they for example allow their
their buyers a lot more leeway on on
Twitter than other organizations do
right and as a result their people tend
to be followed a lot more and a lot more
worth following on Twitter than other
news organizations so they kind of they
get all that stuff which a lot of places
don't I think did you um did you read
snowfall
the the times package that they put
together yeah and what did you think of
that this was a a package of the times
put together about an avalanche that ran
um I think has its own section in the
Sunday paper but uh what was online was
actually much richer yeah then and I
think it's pretty pretty amazing
actually the uh the person who created
that story I was at the Ted conference
uh just yesterday and she was talking
about uh their process for your testing
a lot of things and thinking about the
user experience where does this
multimedia content get too much in the
way of The Narrative of the story right
so it's not a matter of just kind of you
know putting up a bunch of uh of of
interactive Graphics there's a craft
there I'm thinking about
um how is this conveying information to
the reader and how these things actually
complement one another instead of just
having different static elements that
are kind of lumped together on an overly
busy page that's difficult right right
but the fact that they are thinking
about this user experience in a way
um is is important
um all right I think we have time for
one more question
hi my name is Tom pounds I'm here as an
alumnus of this loan School
um depending on what news outlets we
favor we could all get concern to one
degree or another about either voters
fraud or voter suppression
do you think the success of your result
in the last election should give us
confidence in our voting infrastructure
and system and how much sleep do you
lose over that issue
um
well you know I mean what we talk about
what are the what are the social
benefits of of polling right and and
yeah one of them is that um in theory
you're you're serving what the average
man or woman on the street things but
another one is that it can serve as
something of a check
um against massive electoral fraud
potentially
um you know I tend to think that these
problems are are pretty overstated uh by
by both parties and maybe um the fact
that the polling does do a pretty good
job is
is partly a testament to this um but you
have Rojo's complain about for example
illegal immigrants registering to vote
and you know North Carolina didn't audit
on this and you I think you had eight
people right I have a state where you
have five million voters so it's
non-zero for instance
um you know they're kind of often
Democratic conspiracies about what
boating machines are doing
um you know I think they're kind of
often uh Democrats are missing the
low-hanging fruit there right which is
that well how about people have to stand
in line for three hours to Miami right
right yeah Miami or even in New York
City right there's no shadowy conspiracy
there right just a tangible fact right
or for example why do we even require
people to um to register in advance at
all we're in States like Wisconsin or
North Dakota we can register on the same
day turnouts quite a bit higher why do
you have to go to a physical polling
place to vote now where I can from um
from the comfort of my phone now
transfer twenty thousand dollars from uh
from my checking account to my savings
account if I want or unlimited amounts
of money right but um but I have to go
to the polling place to actually vote so
I think people uh sometimes love these
conspiratorial stories about how oh the
votes been been suppressed and missed
ways it would make it a lot easier
people to vote um just in very
elementary ABC kind of reforms well
um I want to thank all of you for coming
um a big thanks to Nate who arrived
thank you
um who arrived in Boston at six this
morning after a red-eye flight from
California so he could be here
um uh you were you were shockingly
eloquent considering the amount of sleep
you must have had I'm probably so much
now that I get excited or tomorrow's
March 1st I think right so you have new
in-flight magazines
on March 1st
um uh this is uh this has been a great
form thank you all for the questions and
uh we hope we see you later in the
semester